how's it going everyone we just got some
new photos from Avengers infinity war
and they are awesome if you would like
to enter the giveaway I'm doing to win a
copy of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment below with your favorite
superhero I've seen Avengers infinity
war a lot and there's something about
the still photos that just make you
appreciate it even more I'm not going to
do really too much of a breakdown here
because I think these photos speak for
themselves they're really really awesome
I just wanted you all to see them I will
talk about a few however starting with
this one of Captain America because we
all love Captain and this is a cool
photo it's kind of shot from through
tree leaves here's what it looks like
and it's black and white you can see the
scar in his head his fist is clenched
it's an awesome photo Black Panthers to
the left of them you can kind of see but
I love this photo because we all love
cash
okay no this is comfy my bid free hi I'm
Steve Rogers this photo is really cool
we have black widow and a Koyie we also
have some what Condon's in the
background one is injured and the others
look like they're going to the aid of
him and judging by the expression on
black widow and a coy use face this is
right where Thor hits the ground this is
one of my favorites because I love
Doctor Strange it's a really cool photo
to me because obviously there is no CGI
in a photograph and it sort of just
makes me appreciate the acting even more
same thing here in this photo I love
star-lord he's hilarious and he's been
one of my favorite characters for a
really really long time and this is the
scene where he kind of has to make an
impossible choice he has to either kill
Gamora who he loves or stop the mad
Titan from destroying half of the
universe
[Music]
[Music]
these two photos of vision and Wanda I
really like because I've always loved
the love story between vision and Wanda
two people who all they want to do is
fit in and then they find each other and
they sort of find their place in this
world with each other so I really love
these photos this photo of nebula is
something that we did not see in the
movie she's sitting on Titan after fan
OSIS snap and she just realizes that all
is lost this one obviously ridiculously
awesome it's of the Mighty Thor he just
landed in Wakanda and started kicking
names didn't you have these two photos
of Black Panther which are just super
awesome one he's attacking in midair
looks like Liu Kang from Mortal Kombat
and the other one looks like he just
landed on the floor from an attack this
one is a behind the scenes look at Tony
Stark and spider-man or Peter Parker on
the floor right before he's about to
turn to dust which everybody can pretty
much agree was one of the saddest
moments in the movie that and the last
words that Groot said to Rocket
I don't feel so good
you're alright I don't I don't know
what's happening I don't want to go
don't want to go please
this super-awesome photo of Thor right
here holding the forge open so he can
make Stormbreaker to go on to defeat
Thanos which he could have done if he
would have aimed for the head but then
we wouldn't have an Avengers 4 so I'm
alright
[Music]
now and the last one that I think is the
best is just an absolutely amazing photo
of Ironman you can see all of the super
intricate detail that they put into the
nanotechnology suit his arms are up he's
about to attack it's an awesome photo
and he started it all ten years ago
Ironman launched the first film of the
MCU
so there are the new still photos from
Avengers infinity war you can also check
them out on my Twitter and Instagram and
another reminder about the giveaway I'm
doing for your chance to win a copy of
Avengers infinity war on blu-ray all you
have to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero you
can also increase your chances of
winning by following me on social media
thank you so much for your support and
watching this video
woof woof
[Music]